hello it's seven o'clock you're watching
Sky News breakfast these are our top
stories here this morning a major rescue
operation is underway in County Donegal
in Ireland after three people were
killed in an explosion at a service
station
it's something that doesn't happen
um
in this part of the world in a rural
community and it's basically the
location of the shop which is it's a
community hub
former Tory Minister Connor Burns says
the party has rushed to judgment after
he was sacked following allegations of
serious misconduct
I'm at Houston Station more rail strikes
and travel chaos ahead as thousands of
rail workers walk out with only one in
five train Services running
more mass graves are uncovered in
Ukraine as Ukrainian troops Race Against
Time to win back as much of their land
as possible before the winter sets in
Liverpool
it's Liverpool the city will host next
year's Eurovision song contest on behalf
of Ukraine after beating Glasgow in a
runoff
[Applause]
in sport England get their women's Rugby
World Cup campaign underway in style as
they run in 14 tries in a big win over
Fiji
in the weather most places will be dry
with plenty of sunshine but there will
be a few showers in the Breezy Northwest
and coming up to Quarter Two we'll take
a look at the papers with the former
editor of the Daily Star Donald Nissan
and the writer and journalist Leslie
Riddick
[Music]
foreign
good morning to you welcome to Sky News
breakfast a major search operation is
continuing at the site of an explosion
at a petrol station in Ireland in which
three people died it's feared that the
number of dead could rise with several
people still missing after the explosion
in the village of Crisler in County
Donegal the Irish Prime Minister Michael
Martin has spoken of the sense of shock
and utter Devastation in the community
from there our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins reports
yourself
the devastating aftermath of an
unthinkable tragedy in County Donegal
emergency teams searched through the
night for those reported missing
we see more clearly than ever before the
power of a good Community
people on the one hand devastated with a
shared sense of worry and anxiety and
and
impending loss and then on the other
hand
I heard from McCarthy that at the very
beginning they were astounded at how
readily and quickly members of the
community rest up and and were doing all
in their power to to try and help
the service station was busy when the
explosion rocked chrislock apartments
above collapsed onto the shop below
trapping those inside
a Coast Guard helicopter supported the
ambulance service in transporting
casualties local people were digging
through the debris to reach them when
help arrived
it's something that's something that
doesn't happen and
in this part of the world in a rural
community and especially the location of
the shop which is it's a community Hub
it's where people met
especially at three o'clock on a Friday
evening and
there's a lot of people be there and
it's just just difficult
Letterkenny General Hospital activated
its major incident protocol and the
Northern Ireland fire and rescue service
crossed the border to assist with
specialist equipment
there is disbelief here where people are
waiting for news of their relatives
friends and neighbors and even though
the search and Recovery operation has
gone on for ours they still don't want
to contemplate that the potential
outcome
Ireland's prime minister anti-shock
mihal Martin said his thoughts were with
the community and what he described as
one of the darkest days for Donegal and
the entire country
David Blevins Sky News at Chris lock
County Donegal
the now former trade
trade to judgment after he was sacked
following allegations of serious
misconduct let's bring in Rob Powell
who's in Westminster for us this morning
to tell us more and Rob certainly very
Swift action by the Prime Minister on
this so what details do we have we don't
have many details uh really Anna all we
know is that this allegation of serious
misconduct has been made towards Conor
Burns it's thought that this related to
something that happened at the Tory
Party Conference that took place in
Birmingham in the early part of this
week and over last weekend but other
than that I don't think Connor Burns has
even been told what the specific
allegation is we do know though that the
MP for Bournemouth West has lost the
Tory party whip that basically means
that he doesn't sit as a conservative MP
anymore he's also been sacked from his
job as a government Minister as a trade
Minister by Liz truss he's also been
suspended as a patron of LGBT plus
conservative grouping now Connor Burns
probably isn't a terribly well known
bigger and eight in The Wider world he
is a relatively influential MP though
someone that was very close to Boris
Johnson someone that was really part of
that core team that kept Boris Johnson
in power through the various scandals
that rocked the last 12 months of his
Premiership he has said he intends to
defend himself he said that he hasn't
been told what any of the allegations
are but that he will cooperate and is
hopeful of clearing his name as well
he's clearly somewhat frustrated about
the speed at which all of this has
happened saying he hopes that the
conservative party inquiry is as speedy
and as quick as it is that they have
rushed to judgment as he puts it I think
though it was politically important for
Liz trust to act quickly on this you'll
remember that Boris Johnson was
frequently accused of not taking
misconduct allegations seriously enough
his downfall was essentially brought on
by allegations that a minister in his
government Christopher pincher had
groped two men in a central London Club
so I think Liz trust wanting to show
that she takes this stuff seriously and
that will not hesitate to act an
unwelcome development but she may well
be applauded for the rapid nature in
which she's acted for now though we
await this conservative party
investigation to run its course and to
find out what exactly did or didn't
happen
indeed let's wait and see what more
details we do get Rob thanks very much
indeed
now over 40 000 rail workers at Network
Rail and 15 train companies who belong
to the rmt union are striking today in
an ongoing dispute overpay jobs and
conditions well joining me now from
Houston Station in central London is
Skies uh Emma birchley morning to you
Emma so another Saturday another strike
at just how badly Will services be hit
then today do we think
well on paper in theory one in five
trains should be running but the
knock-on impact across the train
services in this country will be immense
and for passengers there will be a
certain amount of frustration because
there were strikes on Wednesday there
were strikes as well last Saturday
but as far as the unions are concerned
this is action which is absolutely
necessary they want guarantees on jobs
not being lost they want guarantees on
pay and a pay rise and on conditions now
as far as Network Rail and the rail
bosses are concerned what's needed is
modernization they say there need to be
efficiencies in the whole system that
since the pandemic rail passenger
numbers have fallen and so these
efficiencies are vital but the fact is
these workers are out here early on the
picket line determined to stay the
course and the unions say that they are
in for the Long Haul
yeah well it's one to watch and I will
be talking to Mick Lynch from the rmt
shortly about this um for the moment
though Emma thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at some of today's
other main stories around and the police
Watchdog is investigating after a man
with a knife was fatally shot by armed
officers in a police station car park in
Derby the incident happened at Ascot
Drive police station on Friday morning
detectives say that it's not linked to
terrorism the iopc says a knife has been
recovered from the scene
Liz trouser said to be considering
handing government cash to parents
instead of to nurseries to spend it as
they see fit the current Child Care
Subsidy system sees payments made to
approved providers where all three and
four-year-olds in England are entitled
to 15 hours of free child care a week
new data shows a rise in the number of
NHS and emergency workers seeking help
for having suicidal thoughts according
to the Laura Hyde Foundation
946 workers contacted the charity for
support in the first half of this year
that's almost double the number from
last year most were nurses midwives
medical students and Hospital doctors
aged 40 or under
foreign
Ukraine says two Mass Graves have been
found in areas recently recaptured by
their forces in the east of the country
the Ukrainian governor of the Donetsk
region says one of the sites around the
town of Lehman contains about 200 Graves
including those of civilians he says a
second site also contains the bodies of
civilians and soldiers Russian troops
have withdrawn from the area in recent
days
well the Russian threat of using nuclear
weapons in Ukraine has brought a new
menace to the battlefield but it appears
to have made Ukrainian Frontline
soldiers even more determined to drive
Russian troops out of their country last
week Russia illegally annexed four
regions of Ukraine including the areas
of zaparita Herson in the South and
luhansk and Donetsk in the east
but Ukraine's counter-offensive has
pushed Russian forces back our special
correspondent Alex Crawford and her team
have now reached task the last Village
before the Border Crossing into the
luhansk region and from there she sent
this report
there's no let up on the Eastern Front
Line
the ukrainians are making strong
progress they've got the Russians on the
run and they're pushing them further and
further back into the donbass
they're still managing to take them by
surprise
ambushing Russian vehicles and trapping
their troops
the ukrainians were laying in wait for
these Soldiers the Russians are being
massively outmaneuvered here and the
ukrainians are pulverizing their enemies
they're on the doorstep of lahansk with
the town of criminal in their sights and
it's the gateway to the region
Small Arms fire shows the two sides are
in very close contact
[Music]
there's constant shelling and there are
jets in the air
those are all bombs raining down around
the city
everything will be Ukraine he's shouting
to us
the Russians are suffering significant
losses nothing not even threats of
nuclear attacks are enough to deter the
ukrainians
[Music]
foreign
for whatever comes their way
but thoughts of death are never far away
are you ready
the challenges facing the Ukrainian
troops are only likely to grow
they're already considerable but with
the seasons changing military vehicles
are often the only way of getting
through a lot of this territory
and these two will start struggling soon
so there's a race to keep ahead of this
deteriorating weather which will make
all this even more impenetrable
s
not the lack of determination or the
wave of momentum that they're riding
it's this mud down here and the cold
which was dropped around the corner
the front line residents are now burying
the Russian soldiers they're finding
often Under Fire
he came to our land to kill Anna tells
us
she'd only just retired now she feels
lucky if she lives through each night
that's
Battlefield success rarely comes without
a heartbreaking cost
Alex Crawford Sky News and tours gate on
the Eastern Front Line
Liverpool will host the 2023 Eurovision
song contest for Ukraine after beating
Glasgow in a runoff the contest brings
in enormous viewing figures across the
world and it'll be coming to the city
next spring with the Grand Final taking
place on the 13th of May 2023 our Sky
correspondent Katarina vitotsi was there
when the announcement was made
thank you
it was the moment they'd been hoping for
[Applause]
Liverpool
Liverpool beating Glasgow to become next
year's Eurovision hosts
I love Eurovision and it's just to be in
my home City it's amazing
I can't describe how I feel I'm just
elated I've had this gut feeling all day
it is going like it's gonna be a
Liverpool there was no way in my mind it
was going to be Glasgow sorry sorry but
it was going to be us I'm just excited
for it to start when's it starting let's
do it now I can't wait yeah the contest
will head to the city in May and bring a
massive boost so many people who will
want to just experience the whole
Eurovision like feel and excitement and
it's definitely something that will come
to not only this bus but to all the bars
in the area
um and it's just something that we're so
excited but I know everyone else right
there so excited for as well so yeah
it's gonna be brilliant congratulations
so why in Liverpool well the 2008
European capital of culture has music
built into its very foundations you
might not come to Liverpool for the
weather but you would certainly stay for
the music from The Beatles to Cilla
Black to 1993 Eurovision runner-up Sonia
this is a city with some serious Musical
clouds
and for some this wind feels incredibly
poignant
Ukraine won the last competition but
because of the war can't host it so
Liverpool's success feels extra special
for the Ukrainian refugees who now call
the city home it's more than just the
Eurovision it's more just a song a song
is awesome
rise our mood it's also cheering us up
and cheering people up because when when
they stay in Ukraine they also like to
think in hard moments in happy moments
so this like all music will all gather
us again together and shows that
everything is is fine will be even
better
[Music]
and perhaps that's eurovision's enduring
appeal all that Glitter froth and fun
for some provides a moment of diversion
a moment of joy
catalyptopsy Sky News in Liverpool
now the S P's annual conference is
getting underway in Aberdeen today with
a possible second Scottish referendum
high on the agenda and joining me now
from Aberdeen is the snp's Deputy
Westminster leader Kirsten Oswald so
very good morning to you thanks so much
for talking to us and on the subject of
an independence referendum the UK
Supreme Court is due to rule next week
on whether or not the SMP has the
authority to hold one in October next
year so what will you do if the ruling
goes against you
well let's take this one step at a time
so you know you're right the Supreme
Court will hear the case next week and
uh you know I'm sure that we are all
waiting uh with anticipation to hear
what they say
um however obviously that is part of a
root map if you like to enable us to
facilitate the referendum that we have
uh a very clear mandate to deliver
that's the uh the promise that was made
to the people in Scotland
um when the recent Hollywood elections
took place
um that there's been a commitment to
deliver the independence referendum and
of course as you would hope and as you
would expect in this Manifesto
commitment is absolutely what the
Scottish government do intend to deliver
so we have the case at the Supreme Court
coming up
um next week obviously it would be far
more straightforward if we were just to
proceed with the referendum and with the
UK government taking a a much more
sensible approach and so that we could
do so however you know at the moment
that know where they are I I would think
they would be useful for them to reflect
upon that because it's not for the the
UK government it's not for Liz trust or
anyone else to stand in the way of
democracy in Scotland well she uh said
that she doesn't want a second
referendum in Scotland for the time
being and um I have read that the s p
have said that if they do fail in the
courts next week they would call the
next general election effectively a
referendum on Scotland's Independence is
that right is that something that you do
intend to do and if so how would that
work
and you know if I can first of all go
back to the the first point that you
made uh you know Liz truss has said that
she doesn't want us to have a referendum
now now the the thing is that actually
that's quite important because it is not
up to those trusts it's not up to any
government at Westminster or anyone else
actually for that matter to stand in the
way of what has
um been a key part of the platform that
the Scottish government has been elected
on in Scotland we have a an independent
supporting Parliament the people in
Scotland have voted for The msps Who sit
there and it's absolutely right that the
Scottish government should seek to
deliver upon the Mandate that it was
elected
politicians
we don't have a huge amount of time so I
don't want to go over the same ground
but Liz trusser said that she doesn't
want that to go ahead so would you call
the next general election effectively uh
a an election about the about
independence solely Nicholas surgeon's
been very clear on that so you know
absolutely if the the Supreme Court um
does not rule um in the way that I I
would hope it would and you know if
there isn't a break of common sense in
the UK government then you know yes
that's absolutely a road that we would
travel down but I do think that we
should take one step without the time in
all of this well it's up to any
political party to say out their
platform for any election and that's
what we would do that that's what
happens in any election and you know I
think we're all familiar with that in a
in a general sense so you know this is
um very much the the same Theory but
being applied in a very specific way I
would say though that we do you know
need to take one step at a time because
this court hearing is coming up next
week
um you know I think that it's it's
sensible for us to you know go forward
what one piece
um at a time but yes that absolutely is
it the the route that we would travel
down and that's been kind of really
clearly in the Scottish Parliament by
the first Minister people know what they
voted for they know what to expect
that's what we will deliver and as you
can imagine after not having uh an
in-person conference for a few years
because of the covet pandemic people um
are really excited about Gathering here
at the SMP conference in Aberdeen so
that we are able to have him a few days
of really interesting discussion and
debate about this and of course it's so
Stark for people why Independence now
more than ever is absolutely needed with
all of the the chaos and the the damage
that the UK government is causing to
people all over Scotland and Beyond okay
and and you say it's needed but is the
public behind it there I mean there was
a Salvation poll that suggested just 35
percent of Voters in Scotland agreed
that a referendum on leaving the UK
should take place next year and it's an
expensive business as well it's a lot of
money to spend at a time when
money is so stretched in the cost of
living crisis well I mean money is so
stretched and the cost of living crisis
is so pressing upon people and you know
the the way that the UK government has
conducted itself in all of this is
frankly disgraceful and is having a
really profound impact on the lives of
people all over Scotland and all over
the UK so that is a absolutely a clear
reason why we need to aim and we
absolutely can do better but you know
there was a recent Scottish social
attitudes survey which your viewers may
wish to have a look at which indicated
that 52 of people in Scotland are
supportive of this and you know I think
that the the principle of democracy has
to underpin all of it as well the the
way that we assess what people's views
are the way that we determine the way
forward is through the referendum which
we have a mandate to hold and that's
absolutely what we should do Scotland
can do so much better than being in the
position it is now where we're focused
on this cost of living crisis which the
Scottish government is doing its
absolute utmost to mitigate but we
cannot with one hand tied behind our
back do what is necessary to support
people through this crisis and this
crisis which is being exacerbated by the
extremely irresponsible actions of a UK
government which I I think you know we
can all see having a terrible impact
upon households all over the country
okay and I'm sure lots of those issues
will be discussed over the next few days
and we can explore them another time
when we have more time but for the
moment Kirsten Oswald the SMP thanks
very much indeed for joining us this
morning
let's take a quick look at the weather
now
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today's going to be mainly fine but
more wind and rain will move into the
north and west tomorrow most places will
have a dry clear and chilly start but
there'll be a few blustery showers in
the Northwest and any mist and fog is
going to be isolated showers will
continue to affect northern and western
Scotland through the morning where it'll
be Breezy
let's go back to the rail strikes this
morning where only 20 of train services
will be running as normal because of the
ongoing dispute over jobs pay and
conditions but we can now speak to Mick
Lynch the General Secretary of the
national Union of rail Maritime and
transport workers the rmt a very good
morning to you Mick Lynch and thanks
very much indeed for waiting I know
you've been waiting for us for a while
so appreciate that thanks very much
indeed and so I think we spoke this time
last Saturday so here we are again what
progress if any has been made between
now and last week
well we've had the new secretary of
state make some positive statements at
the Tory conference but we haven't seen
a change at the negotiating table what
we need to see
is a change of stance from the company
so that we can develop a compromise
that all the parties in this dispute can
can support but at the moment we haven't
had a change in the stance uh
is given to the companies Network Rail
and the train operators are delivering a
mandate directly from the Tory
government and until their stance
changes and we hear a lot of hostile
noises about what they're going to do to
trade unions
and what they're going to do to our
members and we need a change of tone
really and a change of uh stance at the
negotiating table so there's there are
no new offers that I can report to you
I'd love to I'd love to hear a new offer
I'd love to see something written down
the piece of paper that we that changes
the
changes the dynamic of this dispute but
it's simply not there at the moment they
want to cut thousands of jobs they won't
give us a pay rise and they want to rip
up our conditions so it's the same as we
had back in the spring when they started
well yes and I think lots of people will
be quite probably quite familiar with
with the arguments on each side now in
this dispute because it's been going on
for a while but I am interested to to
know what your feeling is about the
change of leadership in government and
what effect that could have because you
were telling me last week that you'd met
the new transport secretary Anne-Marie
trevelyn felt that that was a quite a
positive meeting and yet we have Liz
truss talking about saying to Strikers
go back to work so what do you think
might have shifted
well what we we see is sort of two
two-edged sword is a good cop bad cop so
the Secretary of State for transport is
saying that she wants a settlement she's
asked us to get around the table and she
said they want the landing zone for the
dispute and we I agree with that that's
what we all want we want a place where
we can all get to that will resolve the
issues but at the same time the
chancellor takes time out from a
financial statement that says they're
going to re-regulate and re-legislate
about trade unions they're going to try
and smash us up they're going to they
want to make disputes virtually illegal
in the future they want to finance
millions of pounds for if we make a
mistake in a ballot so it's a you know
it's two faces to the to the same clock
and what we need is a consistent message
from the government that they want to do
a deal with us and they've got to allow
the the chief Executives and the HR
directors that I sit with to make an
agreement we know what the agreement
takes and they know that what the
government is asking them to push
through in this industry is not
acceptable to the trade unions We're Not
Gonna
except the chopping up of our conditions
we don't want to see the erosion of our
pensions and our members want a pay rise
it's a very I mean these are very
straightforward issues if you've not had
a pay rise for three years as a worker
you're obviously going to demand that
your union does something about that and
that's what we're trying to achieve
we want a reasonable settlement and we
know that we can get there but it's the
government that seems to me that's
stopping this thing developing
audience
announcing at these new rules that will
effectively make strike action harder
presumably the calculation is that the
public are frustrated by strikes do you
think there is a risk that you will lose
public sympathy the longer you carry on
and how long do you think this will go
on for
well we know that it's difficult for the
public to travel in public don't want to
be disrupted who does but what we see
around the country are more and more
people who are fed up with the way
they're being treated at work and more
sectors of the economy and services are
coming into dispute the Royal College of
nurses that have never had a strike in
their entire Hundred Year history a
balloting now the doctors are balloting
we've had barristers out on strike all
sorts of people are just fed up with the
way that this country has run at the
minute with the rich seem to be getting
richer and the poor seem to be worse off
all the time and the government made a
big mistake and maybe they're looking
for an enemy maybe they think the rnt
and Railway workers are their enemy but
we we don't see that on the picket line
we see lots of people supporting us
people are coming out on demonstrations
in support of the trade unions and
they're really getting behind us so I
don't think the public are annoyed at
the uh the railway workers I think the
public have got a lot of Sympathy For
What our members are going through and
members are losing their wages they're
fully committed to this dispute and they
want a settlement but we're not just
going to accept any old rubbish that
they throw it as frankly
okay well Mick Lynch we appreciate your
time this morning there at Houston
Station thanks very much indeed for
talking to us
now the Prime Minister Liz tras has
ruled out launching an energy saving
public information campaign despite
warnings that three hour power blackouts
could be imposed in some areas of the
country but in the 1970s they encouraged
people to switch off something
industry needs power
so do hospitals so do essential services
at home you could get by with men so
switch off from power now
so that was a blaster in the past from
the 1970s there well if you're in need
of advice on saving money on your energy
bills in the 21st century consumer
expert Kate Hardcastle might have the
answers as you can see she joins me now
very good morning to you Kate nice to
see you
um so let's just go straight in shall we
give us a few tips on how to save energy
because obviously cutting back is going
to help people with their bills
I will do but I think I've probably got
to put a little bit of a preface there
in which is that we are sadly perhaps
looking at this situation where saving
money is the focus because a lot of
families are having to do that I think a
lot of families are already making great
inroads with with balancing the books in
terms of their budget each week we seem
to be going from a situation where we
could spend previous years talking about
how to cut perhaps your shopping budget
by switching to supermarket how to get a
better deal on your insurance and now
we're looking at very brutal realities
of having to just limit your food
shopping and limit your fuel supply and
I think that's the challenge for a lot
of consumers that said I think sometimes
we have got to a point where we are
quite relaxed about the usage and it's
all about trying to get maximum
efficiency out of your home making sure
that you are using as you need rather
than you want and just getting into
great habits and a positive spin is
that's going to just help you generally
with your bills and make sure that
you're not using things you don't one a
lot of us leave products on standby that
we don't need to leave it's an extra
switch off every night and I can
understand completely why people don't
really want to do that but that will
help we've got to look at those big
draining devices like washing machines
and Tumble dryers can you and do you
genuinely wash at a lower temperature 30
I find to be effective as a temperature
on the majority of the things we wash
each week and by making sure that I am
full loading capacity of the machine I'm
getting maximum usage out of that it's
really important to make sure that you
understand if every radio is radiator in
the house and boiler system is as
efficient as it can be it might be well
worth as well some organizations like
British gas do offer a monthly care
package if that's affordable to you
perhaps if you've got an older device it
might be worth looking into that if over
the winter that might be something you
want to switch to to make sure if
there's any essential repairs you're
able to get cover but also that you can
get an expert into your home to make
sure that you're getting best of it and
I think the best as well is he you
rather than the home a home sometimes
can be a little bit large and they've
got a lot of places that that hot air
can go to so I love a lot of the the
um elements where you just you're just
layering up you're putting more layers
on yourself I've got actually a heated
blanket you can wear and I just wear it
in the office because I don't need to
hold heat the whole office I need to
heat me but I do feel quite sad trying
to give out this advice I've got to be
honest on it because we must question
why we've got to this point in the first
place well yeah and that's a whole other
debate isn't it as well as the one of
whether or not there should be a
government Campaign which is obviously
exercising Minds all over the place but
really helpful tips Kate thanks very
much indeed
um and lots of information online as
well isn't there shorter showers
changing to LED lights there are lots of
different things you can do as well okay
thanks very much indeed thanks
still come here on Sky News at breakfast
we're going to go through the papers for
you I'll be joined by the former editor
of the Daily Star Dawn Nissim and the
writer and journalist Leslie Riddick to
talk us through some of the stories
inside and on the front pages
[Music]
time for our pay-per-view now here with
me this morning to go through the papers
are the former editor of the Daily Star
Donald Nissan and the writer and
journalist Leslie Riddick so welcome
back to both of you nice to see you back
again
um so Leslie we're kicking off this
section with the front page of the Daily
Mirror and this is uh the next round of
covert Jabs that some of us are due for
and they're calling it a booster jab
crisis so why is it a crisis
well it seems that there's there's uh
older folk are are less Keen to come
forward but actually when you really
look into the statistics it feels like
that the campaign hasn't really totally
got going yet it is the case already
that people who are vulnerable folk who
are in the front line people in Care
Homes uh these these people can come
forward for the booster Jags but there's
a lot of issues sitting at the back of
this
um some immunologists are trying to
point out that uh having covert doesn't
give you very much immunity to the next
variant and there might be a belief
amongst people that if you've actually
had covered by now you're sort of doing
all right and there's also a flu jike
that's coming up perhaps older people
are beginning to think one will sort of
deal with the other or the two Jags at
the same time is too much who knows
because there isn't really a full-on
campaign if you want to get a covered
test and you haven't got any tests from
the last time it's actually 10 quid to
buy a test so it feels feels like we're
cranking up towards something which
could be really serious I mean some of
the professionals are calling it
potentially a twin damic because we
haven't really had flu in a big way for
the last couple of years because covert
kind of edged it out so the potential to
have something pretty bad this year if
we don't have covert and flu Jags seems
to be quite large and at the moment it's
the over 70s who seem to be the ones who
are are most at risk of Contracting
covert whereas the previous strains were
very much more spreading amongst young
people and sorry just one quick question
which I don't know if you know the
answer to Leslie but is this something
that people will be invited to do like
we have been previously you'll get a
text or something saying you can now
book your your booster or do people go
to their GPS and say can I have one do
you know how it's working
well I've been drilling down to try and
see that and of course it's different in
England and Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland but it would seem at the moment
that those over 65s are being invited
and have been since September in a
ruling program to come forward but what
the NHS in England is saying now
um is that over 50 should be included in
that I should imagine that would mean
that the tax and those sorts of methods
of contact will begin to resume
yeah interesting but I haven't had one
you'll be amazed to hear that I'm over
50. I know that's staggering news but
anyway I will let you know if it comes
through um let's move on to the times at
shall we Dawn um their main headline
parents get cash payout in child care
reform plan so what is the thinking
behind this plan of list trusses
yeah it's a drawing up plans to um
convoluted
to the UK at the moment a present
parents of all three and four-year-olds
in England can claim 15 hours of free
child care a week which amounts to
around
um two thousand pounds per child per
year now this currently is paid to the
nursery care provider rather than the
parents um what this trust is suggested
in these new plans which are being drawn
up it's not definitely going to happen
it is a plan
um is that that money is paid directly
to the parents to decide how they spend
it which in theory means that they could
use the money to pay grandparents who
are looking after their grandchildren
for example rather than the nursery care
and this is obviously in the light of
nursery care prices absolutely being
extortionate now but I think one of the
most important things about this story
is that uh Liz trust would win a lot of
brownie points if she really helped out
working women in this country sort out
Child Care arrangement I know men look
after kids as well but it's mainly women
um look after children and manage to get
back in the workforce we have a labor
shortage at the moment and I think women
are crying out for this kind of help
yeah and really interesting it seems to
feed in very much that um Liz trust
ideology of putting people's money in
their pockets and then making letting
them make their own decisions but I'm
sure there are plenty of arguments
around that and let's move on to yeah
which unfortunately haven't got time to
go into now but because Leslie I want to
bring you in on um the s p conference
kicks off uh today there's also a ruling
next week on whether or not an
independence referendum can go ahead
next year isn't there and what is the
eye saying about some of the issues that
that throws up
uh well yes I'm speaking actually from a
hotel room in Aberdeen about to go to
the SNP conference um and uh the eye
story is the the news from Nicholas
Durden that she will be publishing a
paper next week
um outlining the ideas of a Scottish
pound and the the old policy Last Time
Around in 2014 from Alex salmon was that
uh there would be a shared currency
George Osborne said that won't happen
you could actually have a shared
currency but that didn't sound like a
very good strong Arrangement so in
between there's been a growth commission
uh in Scotland that suggested a slow
move away from Sterling to a Scottish
currency a lot of strict tests were
suggested for that could take a very
long time and of course in the interim
the tanking of the pound has rather
accentuated the point that leaving
monetary decisions with the Westminster
Bank of of England uh combination would
be a pretty dodgy thing for a new
country now of course you know any new
currency also has to get established it
would have a central bank that would be
established straight after independence
vote and that's all in the paper that
will come up next week but as you say
the thing that will concentrate Minds at
the moment is that the Supreme Court is
meeting next week to decide whether or
not the world's most powerfully devolved
Parliament as we're told Scotland has
can actually hold a legal referendum
I'll see you both next hour
oh